[Music]
so peter dinklage is a hollywood actor
and uh a little person a person of short
stature an individual of less than
average height a human of smaller
persuasion i'm not sure what the
politically correct term is these days i
think dwarf is still okay though for
some reason [ __ ] has been thrown out
in any case well you could choose which
label makes you feel the most
comfortable what matters today is that
dinklage is bravely speaking out against
the woke snow white remake currently in
the works over at disney although his
complaint is that it's not nearly woke
enough obviously now as we know disney
has been diligently focused on ripping
off degrading mutating mutilating
destroying all of their own classics and
not just their classics either even
their middle tier cartoons like the
aristocats have been placed on the
docket for remakes in this case a live
action remake i'm told it's not exactly
clear how a movie about talking cats
could be live action but
you know
that's neither here nor there snow white
is a little bit easier to reimagine in
that format
and to wokify
so the new version will feature disney's
first latina
excuse me latinx disney princess
the non-white princess will play a
character who is named snow white
literally because according to the
original fairy tale her skin is white as
snow
now recasting a character like this with
a non-white actress
it's like recasting black panther with
chris pat pratt in the in the lead role
of course if disney did something like
that there would be riots in the street
al sharpton would rappel down from a
helicopter and hold a press conference
denouncing them
it would be unthinkably offensive to
cast a white actor in a traditionally
non-white role whereas it is unthinkably
offensive to complain about the reverse
happening those are the rules
and yet none of this is enough to
satisfy peter dinklage who took some
time on marc maron's wtf podcast to
complain about the insufficient wokeness
of disney's woke snow white let's listen
i was a little
taken back by the
very very they're very proud to cast a a
a latino actress as snow white yeah but
you're still telling the story of snow
snow white yeah seven dwarfs sure
look take take a step back and look at
what you're doing there makes no sense
to me well oh so
you're progressive in one way and then
but you're still making that
backward oh story about seven dwarves
living in a cave what the [ __ ] are you
doing man we you know
have i have i done nothing to advance
the cause
from my soapbox
i guess i'm not loud enough
uh still i don't know what's new i don't
know what studio that is but there but
it was they were so proud of that and
all love and respect to the to the
actress and to
the people who thought they were doing
the right thing but i'm just like yo you
don't what are you doing
there we go snow white is offensive to
dwarfs
now the film uh i guess i don't know the
film commits some literal micro
aggressions you might say though it must
be noted that contrary to dinklage's
claims the dwarves in snow white they
don't live in a cave first of all they
live in a charming cabin in the woods
they work in a cave
which is actually a mine where they've
apparently discovered a rather lucrative
mineral deposit and they enjoy mining
those resources which is why they
whistle while they work
but perhaps more to the point
the dwarves and fairy tales like snow
white just like the dwarves and fantasy
stories like the lord of the rings are
not
disabled humans who suffer from dwarfism
they're mythical creatures they're like
leprechauns or elves in these stories
if you're going to be offended by
mythical characters because of a vague
physical resemblance
then brian stelter should be offended by
humpty dumpty nancy pelosi should be
offended by corella deville bill de
blasio should be offended by the muppets
but you don't see them complaining
but you do see them complaining just not
about that well uh one thing i could
tell you as a four-star chef myself um
amateur chef but i consider myself a
four-star chef your kitchen is not
complete without
great kitchen knives and that's why you
need cami coda kamikota taps into more
than 800 years of traditional techniques
from honshu japan kamikoda also uses
steel source for mills in japan and each
blade is crafted using techniques that
have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths each knife
comes in a beautiful heavy duty ash wood
box and make sure that the knife is
stored safely as well each kamikota
knife goes through a rigorous 19-step
process that takes several years from
start to finish to complete our expert
blade smiths forge and shape raw steel
into hardy blades
polishing and sharpening them to
excruciatingly fine edge each knife is
individually inspected kamikoto is so
confident that their knives will work
for you that each knife comes with a
lifetime guarantee because of their
single bevel edge candy coated knives
can achieve an unbelievably sharp edge
you just can't get with other knives
they can cut through your rib eye like
butter that is guaranteed uh kamikoto is
currently having a massive extended new
year sale and on top of that sale you
can get an additional fifty fifty
dollars off any purchase you make with
discount code matt wall so click the
link below or go to camcoda.com matt
wall should use promo code matt walsh to
save an extra 50 today now this is all
to say nothing of the fact that dinklage
has already played mythical dwarves in
films many times
he also appeared in the movie elf for
just one scene where the whole joke was
that will ferrell's character thought he
was an elf from the north pole
now this kind of moral hypocrisy is of
course quite common among the woke
especially the older woke many of whom
just decided recently to adopt this
stance over the past like five years
after a lifetime of relative sanity
they've now decided that they could act
a certain way and do certain things and
make certain jokes and indulge in
certain stereotypes and make money in
certain ways but nobody else is allowed
to do it
their views have evolved and now they
have no patience for anyone who fails to
evolve along with them
people who carry on exactly as they did
just 12 seconds ago are persona non
grata i mean what if there were younger
dwarfs like dinklage once was who were
looking forward to the snow white remake
because it would be their chance to
break into the film industry just as he
did
sorry says dinklage that path was open
to him
but it now has to be closed to everybody
else
he's drawing up the bridge behind him no
one else sorry pulling up the ladder
he was the last one through the door
he's locking it behind him and then he's
turning around staring out the window
and sneering at everybody still stuck
outside
and it looks like he'll get his way the
hollywood reporter has a disney
statement about all this quote to avoid
reinforcing stereotypes from the
original animated film we're taking a
different approach with these seven
characters and have been consulting with
members of the dwarfism community we
look forward to sharing more as the film
heads into production after a lengthy
development period a disney spokesperson
said a statement hollywood reporter
still years from release snow white will
have cultural consultants just like
other live-action films such as aladdin
and mulan
the film has been been in development
for three years the studio has been
reimagining the dwarf characters since
the earliest stages
yeah we wouldn't want uh stereotypes of
mythical creatures
perhaps next we can get a campaign to
end the stigma surrounding vampires and
werewolves
so to review
in the new snow white and the seven
dwarves
snow white will no longer be snow white
and the dwarves will no longer be doors
nothing can be what it was before all
that existed in the past is now
offensive simply because it existed in
the past
fairy tales especially
must be abolished and rewritten
as disney has set out to do and this is
why they're doing it well the first
reason they're doing it is for the money
the second is this because fairy tales
cannot be allowed to continue existing
fairy tales commit the aforementi
mentioned sin of being very old and
that's no good
also fairy tales deal with universal
themes and universal themes are
problematic because they don't cater
specifically enough to the particular
concerns of individual victim groups
and fairy tales always revolve around a
conflict of good versus evil but that's
also offensive because the categories of
good and evil require moral judgment and
moral judgment is no longer allowed
moreover and the biggest thing of all is
that fairy tales quite often feature a
romance which is based in traditional
notions of chivalry and gender roles
obviously we can't have any of that
those are the defining elements of fairy
tales and very often the defining
elements of stories in general
that's why we have to move past it it's
time we move past storytelling all
together abolish all films and
television shows and burn all books
we can spend our time sitting in silence
staring at blake blank screens and empty
pages
it's the only way to ensure
that nobody is ever offended
but in the meantime we have to say to
peter dinklage that he is of course
today cancelled listen hit that
subscribe button right now do it right
now i thank you for your compliance it
is
somewhat appreciated